herzlich willkommen martin baumann bei
der sternstunde religion dann kind dass
wir hier sein dass wir sprechen heute
über religion und integration
sie sind deutscher in namibia geboren in
england und deutschland studiert leben
nun aber schon zwölf jahre in der
schweiz sind sie selbst integriert ich
würde sagen ja ich würde bin integriert
wir haben viele meiner familie und ich
viele schweizer freunde im quartier wo
wir wohnen sind wir sehr gut vernetzt
ich helfe beispielsweise mal bei toom
führung in der katholischen kirche mit
meine frau ist sehr gut integriert indem
sie unterricht für migrantinnen gibt und
weitere nierfeld aber sie brauchen im
konjunktiv ich würde sagen dass das
heißt sie empfinden so gibt es dann auch
ein objektives feststellen ihrer ihres
integriert sein ich habe den konjunktiv
gebraucht weil er integration
letztendlich eine form ist die von außen
zugeschrieben wird die sozusagen die
mehrheitsgesellschaft gruppen personen
zu schreibt oder nicht von daher ist
sicherlich das eigene empfinden
ich fühle mich sehr gut integriert aber
ob das andere so sehen das kann ich
selber kontrollieren dadurch oder mit
bekommen indem er es andere sagen dem
sie beispielsweise mit mir
schweizerdeutsch reden dann ist es eine
form von integration
aber wenn ich auf einem straßenfest mein
deutsches bier trinke da ist mir auch
schon gesagt worden du musst dir das
lokale biertrinken dass ich nicht mag um
in trier zu sein ärgert es sie
eigentlich wenn sie auf ihre integration
angesprochen werden ich
weiß es nicht mehr also ich finde es ich
versuche es analytisch zu sehen und
frage mich warum ist diese große
sehr große sozusagen fokus auf dieser
integration in der schweizer
gesellschaft meines erachtens klappt
hier sehr viele sehr gut und ich wundere
mich warum sozusagen diese thematik
problematik so oft hervorgeholt wird der
schweiz ist ein hatten sehr viele sachen
extrem gut und ich finde es eine
thematik die diese zahlen ein bisschen
schwächer auch bei vielen schweizern
zeigt dass immer wieder hervorholen wir
kommen darauf zurück
sie forschen an der uni luzern sind
religionswissenschaftler und
beschäftigen sich schon seit langem sehr
intensiv mit fragen der zuwanderung von
religiösen gemeinschaften und ihrer
gesellschaftlichen integration
ich bin muslimin ich bin in der schweiz
geboren habe einen arabischen und einen
europäischen elternteil wie weiß ich
denn jetzt ob ich integriert
ja das ist die beste die problematik ist
wird ich glaube es wird zugeschrieben
einmal die integration ich glaube für
viele wirkt auf viele
schweizer auf viele die sozusagen
immigranten sind die schweizer sind
schauen sie fühlen sich integriert wenn
sie die sprache sprechen wenn sie einen
job haben wenn sie sozial beruflich
eingegliedert sind finden sie auch
beispielsweise auf bestimmte anlässe
eingeladen werden wenn sie
beispielsweise in den interreligiösen
kreisen wird jetzt der hindu priester
bei uns in luzern eingeladen das ist
eine geste die vorher nicht
stattgefunden hat wenn die universität
luzern jetzt nicht nur mehr der den
kirchenvertretern zu ihrem dies
academicus an den sondern auch andere
religionsvertreter ich denke dass eine
öffnung und es ist ein zeichen er gehört
dazu wir möchten euch dabei haben wenn
integration aber oder das integriert
seien nur von außen zugeschrieben wird
dann kann der einzelne zu integrierender
ja im prinzip ja gar nichts dazu bei
kraft doch er kann sehr viel beitrag in
dem er teilnimmt in dem sich einbringt
in der schweiz ist es sehr deutlich
anzeichen in vereinen mitglied zu sein
ich glaube integration läuft viel
darüber ob man sich austausch mit
anderen in der straße im quartier in der
schule in der universität sankt teilen
dem an den angeboten einer gesellschaft
und in dem sinne ist es natürlich
wichtig zu nachzudenken was heißt
integration eigentlich und ich verstehe
integration als teilhabe als teilhaber
an den angebotenen ressourcen einer
gesellschaft und hier haben für dich
sagen doch großteil der migranten haben
sehr hochgradig anteil an dieser
gesellschaft in den der schule
arbeitsbereiche und ähnlichen teilhaben
und was genau oder wo genau kommen jetzt
die regierung ins spiel wenn es um
integration integration kommt den spiel
fall fremde religion grad muslimische
mitunter auch tamilisch egoistische wird
als sozusagen als ein störfaktor gesehen
als ein hinderungsgrund dass man nicht
guter muslim sein kann und zugleich
guter schweizer sein kann sie finden was
geht ich finde das geht es ja deutlich
gerade verliehen der schweizer
gesellschaft auch in anderen
europäischen gesellschaft wird seine
religion ist seien bei vielen ein
teilbereich ist und nicht mehr der
hauptbestandteil von einem religiösen
von einem leben in der gesellschaft an
und wir haben sehr deutlich gesehen in
den studien sagen religiös seien stabile
hinduistisch sei es tibetisch
buddhistischen muslimisch und guter
bürger eines landes zu sein ist kein
widerspruch und das sehen wir in der
religionsgeschichte schon und wir sehen
es einfach am täglichen zusammenleben
wenn wir mit person entsprechen und
religion steht dort nicht so oft mehr im
vordergrund
sie haben ein buch herausgegeben mit
kollegen das heißt integration durch die
religion mit einem dicken fragezeichen
versehen
sie versprechen geschichtliche befunde
analysen und perspektiven die frage wie
steht es denn um die antworten scheut
sich die wissenschaft eindeutige
antworten zu heben nein sie gibt
antworten aber sie gibt unterschiedliche
sie differenziert sie unterscheidet und
es kommt eben sehr deutlich darauf an
wie sie verstehe ich integration
letztendlich verstehe ich integration
wie ich sie jetzt definiert habe als
teilhaber als eine möglichkeit an der
gesellschaft sich einzubringen eine
ressourcen teilzunehmen oder ist
integration bislang verstand wird und
wie es auch gesellschaftspolitisch in
vielen kreisen verstand wird eigentlich
anpassung anpassung an die bedingungen
der gesellschaften damit sind die
rahmenbedingungen der gesellschaft
gesetzt dann das ist assimilation und
wie wir in unseren gesprächen die ich
sehe ist diese assimilation oft eine
aufgabe von hergebrachten bezügen sei es
familien bezügen seit bestimmten bezügen
wie ich sehe mich als person einbringe
das ich sozusagen meine eigenheit meine
identitäten auf waren möchte und in dem
sinne ist assimilation nicht notwendig
ein konzept was jetzt zu einer
anerkennung auch der immigranten führt
der zugezogene personen aber haben wir
hier nicht ein dilemma sie haben gesagt
wie sie ist integration in erster linie
teilhabe partizipation
die mehrheitsgesellschaft wirklich
behaupten sie dass er als eine anpassung
an die hiesigen gepflogenheiten werden
immer wieder hervorgehoben und die sich
anzupassen gilt wie bringen wie bringen
wir jetzt diese beiden
extreme sozusagen zusammen ich denke im
alltag läuft läuft sehr viel schon
miteinander sehr gut zusammen indem
diese teilhabe eben auch niederschwellig
ist dass sie in teilhabe in beruflichen
beruflichen teil beruflichen bereichen
da ist die kinder werden in den schulen
integriert bekommen hier eben auch die
kontakte da und sind nimmt teil an mit
erster ausbildung ein höherer ausbildung
dann und es ist eine teilhabe die jetzt
eben nicht die sehr viel spannen breiten
hat und ein spektrum aufzeigt dann und
wir haben eben moderne gesellschaft
ausdifferenzierte gesellschaft das heißt
verschiedene bereich haben wir in der
nicht notwendig in allen bereichen
teilhabe ist aber ich denke sehr wichtig
für zugezogene ist die primäre ziel
vorgibt vordergründige teilhabe ist
beruflich eingegliedert zu sein sozial
ein mitgeliefertes wer sich in
jugendgruppen sei es im jugendclub sah
ich den sportverein und so etwas und da
sehe ich doch sehr viel positives was
auch läuft sie
streichen das positiv hervor was schon
gut läuft wenn wir den öffentlichen
diskurs uns anschauen dann könnte das
sehr viel anders
es ist ein politikum es ist ein heißes
eisen
wie sehen sie denn das wie viel muss der
staat vorschreiben an integration
das ist in der tat ein heißes eisen ist
es die frage ob der staat dies überhaupt
vorschreibt oder ob es nicht in der
zivilgesellschaft vorgeschrieben wird
das heißt durch politische parteien
beispielsweise durch meinungsmacher dann
und ich sehe den schweizer eigentlich
wenn ich mit behörden zu tun habe sehe
ich ihn eigentlich relativ entspannt
gerade wenn wir die muslimin frage und
die sozusagen die islam diskussion
ich sehe viele behördenvertreter auf der
nationalen ebene bundesrats eben auf
lokalen gemeinden eigentlich eher
entspannter relativierende
differenzieren und ich sehe politische
parteien die ja die vielleicht auch die
unterschiedlichkeit von muslin seien in
der schweizer gesellschaft nicht so sehr
sehen und ein einheitliches bild zeigen
dann ich denke man muss sehen dass ist
es ist nicht nur alles sozusagen positiv
in den immigranten verein man muss auch
sehen es wert bestimmter druck ausgeübt
teilzunehmen oder vielleicht bestimmte
rollen einzunehmen für frauen für männer
dann also
vereinheitlichten nur das verherrlichen
was in den verein läuft das möchte ich
auch nicht sagen bleiben wir noch einen
moment sie haben eben die islam diskurs
frage angesprochen
es heißt ja immer wieder muslime sind
integrierbar der islam aber nicht wie
stehen sie zu solchen aussagen
ich glaube auch hier muss man einfach
sehen es wird ja pauschalisierend
gesprochen und man versucht eben dann
sich sozusagen dann noch raus zu retten
ich glaube einmal man muss einfach sehr
deutlich sagt islam ist eine gelebte
religion und sie wird in der schweiz
wenn wir uns anschauen wie erst
immigranten wie die jugendlichen das
leben wir sehen eigentlich der großteil
ist relativ distanziert gegenüber der
eigenen religion kommen auf die thematik
der zweiten generation in dem sinne
findig islam muss man sehen wie wir das
praktiziert wie wird es gelebt und und
dass ich einfach es wird nicht der islam
gelebt sondern es werden
unterschiedliche formen von islam gelebt
und verletzt sich in einer bosnischen
moschee da wird mir sehr deutlich betont
die frau des imam sagt mir wir sind
europäische muslime wir gehören schon
seit langem dazu wo wir werden sozusagen
fremd nach außen gedrängt und in dem
sinne find ich der islam ist eine
kategorie die uns eigentlich in den
gesellschaftlichen gespräch diskurs
nicht weiterhilft sondern eine negativ
stadt lohne aufgestellt ist die
sozusagen unvereinbar ist mit schweizer
behörden schweizer demokratieverständnis
aber in einem verständnis was ihren
prozessen gesellschaftlichen essen läuft
ist dies eigentlich nicht hilfreich und
führt auch nicht weit aber interessant
ist doch dass diese frage starken islam
gestellt wird aber wir hören selten
hindus sind integriert aber der
hinduismus lässt sich nicht integrieren
das liegt auch daran dass jede
gesellschaft hat schon ein platz für
eine fremde religion zugezogene religion
in der gesellschaft gemacht windows
genetische buddhisten tibetische
buddhisten sagen auf der positiven seite
sie werden nicht hinterfragt tibetische
buddhisten an den dalai lama der ist
gerade in basel war sie werde nicht
hinterfragt warum werden sie nicht
gefragt ja das ist natürlich weil die
gesellschaft sich auch bestimmte bilder
von den religionen und macht und sie
auch gerne so hat dann und wir haben
muss ja islam war in den 1920 er jahren
beim 19 jahrhundert zum teil das war
sehr verherrlichend weil sozusagen das
bild von 1001 nacht es war bei
intellektuellen in deutschland zum teil
in der schweiz bei islam sozusagen als
rationale natur wissenschaftlich
fundierte religion die auf viel mit
wissenschaften arbeitet da kommt die
mathematik war zum teil auch sehr den in
der zeit was sehr positiv angesehen und
natürlich jetzt mit den terroranschlägen
nach 2001 hatte sich sehr gedreht und
politisch ist ist das sieht man nicht
nur in der schweiz sehen wir in anderen
europäischen ländern ist islam eine
vierte über die hervorragend mobilisiert
werden kann weil wir einen fremden haben
den können wir an eine bestimmte ecke
stellen wenn du uns muslime selber
anschauen wenn wir uns die webseiten
wenn wir mit ihm reden zu sagen
natürlich stehen wir dazu der schweizer
gesellschaft wir haben auf den webseiten
vorne drauf bekenntnis zur schweizer
rechts gesellschaft zu demokratie und
aber wir werden nicht gefragt sondern es
werden bestimmte flohen dann oft gezeigt
in der politischen gesprächen das würde
dann auch heißen dass die anderen
religionsgemeinschaften so etwas aus dem
fokus geraten und sich vielleicht so in
diesem windschatten der islam diskussion
eigenständiger reformieren können nicht
ich mir ein beispiel wir haben kürzlich
erfahren die hinter gemeinde im haus der
religion in bern will einführen dass
auch frauen priesterinnen werden können
ändert die sprach vom sanskrit zum
umgangssprachlichen tamilisch warum ist
er das reformtempo in den
religionsgemeinschaften zu
unterschiedlich
ich glaube man schaut jetzt sehr
deutlich auf diesen tempel in wären weil
er sozusagen genau das bild bedient dass
viele schweizer
politiker vielleicht religionsvertreter
haben sozusagen ein ein moderner
hinduismus oder reformierten hindurch
muss der frauen gleich stellt und so
etwas wir übersehen aber die anderen 20
tempel in denen sehr viel passiert auch
in der auch jugendliche eingezogen
werden in der frauen zum teil
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten haben ich
würde sagen reform tempel wir sehen in
dem muss stehen auch viele reformen in
dem beispielsweise imame wird sich
rollen annehmen müssen die sie in den
herkunftsregionen
gar nicht haben sie sind plötzlich
berater seelsorger sie sind mitunter ein
jobvermittler also
reformtempo
für dich für dich nicht so sehen sondern
das ist jetzt ein sozialen besonderer
fall mit dem hindutempel und wir sehen
der jetzt in den medien gepusht wird es
passiert wird auch viel aber ich denke
die anderen tempel wenn ich jetzt in
dürnten nach oberland sehen welchen
sphären den tempel sehe dort ist
versucht man auch viel sitz haben sich
hier in die gesellschaft einzubringen
und mitzumachen denn für zu schulklassen
zu öffnen für führungen zu öffnen
ähnliches wir werden uns darüber noch
unterhalten jetzt hören wir erst einmal
drei stimmen von jungen muslimen und was
ist für sie heißt ihre religion hier und
heute zu leben
für müßiggang ist
und freund haben islamischen glauben was
ich kann habe ich
angst dass
das haus das weiß ich
der glaube ist für mehr erlauben sagt
und der laden sicherlich und importeure
geht es für mich persönlich
lief jetzt die antwort man sich halt im
verlauf vom lager ausstellt oder aber es
ist für mehr privat sehr persönlich
wir migranten ebel mit 8 jährigen
schweizer und vermischt das nicht immer
sehr einfach sie ausruhen und aus junge
frau zwischen zwei kulturen
zwischen zwei landes wachsen ja sehr
lang in köln irgendwo
haben etwa nicht mazedonisch gefühlt wie
auch nicht richtig schwimmen
kann ich mir wirklich mit mir selber
auseinandergesetzt und auch mit eigener
identität gesucht
und da nicht dass religion wirklich viel
mehr bedeutet für mich aussie aussie das
mak war bis dahin
ja martin baumann das sind drei sehr
unterschiedliche stimmen mir fällt aber
auch auf dass alle drei ein positives
verhältnis formulieren in bezug auf ihre
religion und dass sie sich irgendwo
zwischen religion als lifestyle und
religion als identität bewegen ist das
nun typisch für muslime oder eher
typisch für die zweite generation
ich denke das ist typisch für die zweite
generation was wir in dem fall gesehen
haben in den 23 sozusagen ausschnitten
ist aussagen von personen die für die
religion sozusagen ein vehikel ist ein
weg um identität zu finden sein platz in
der gesellschaft sozusagen zu wissen wo
man steht
der zweite mann war sozusagen sehr
religiös für ihn war religion ein
lebensweg und erste porträt von der
jungen dame war in dem sinne sehr
anschaulich dass es zeigte wie
distanziert man gegenüber religion ist
und bestimmte regeln vorschrift man kein
alkohol zu trinken im islam
überschreitet und wir sehen eigentlich
bei vielen zweit generation sei es
jungen tibetern junge muslime jungen
hindu
das dass wir so eine ein spektrum haben
von von personen die sehr distanziert
gegenüber ihrer religion sind und
welchen diese religiös sind für die das
wichtig ist über diese zwei pole die
empore sind quasi minderheiten sehr
deutlich minderheiten und die größten
bereich sehen wir in personen
jugendlichen die die selektiv religiösen
so haben wir das genannt die mal in die
moschee gehen mal in die hindu tempel
aber für sie ist es jetzt nicht so
lebens bestimmt es ist eine form weil
man den mit den eltern geht mit anderen
freunden dort hingeht falls bestimmten
tageszeiten bestimmten festen aber man
sozusagen auch diesen den spagat
zwischen der welt der eltern den
migranten gemeinschaft und eben der
angebotene hiesigen gesellschaft mit
konsumgesellschaft und ähnlichen diesen
spagat schafft und das so interpretiert
für sich indem man distanziert und
selektiv ist dass wir jetzt gleich mal
eine nächste frage gewesen sie besuchen
ja auch häufig die
religionsgemeinschaften verschiedener
hindurch sicher oder politische
ausrichtungen was erleben sie da gehen
junge tamilische männer und frauen junge
buddhisten tibeter gehen die noch so
selbstverständlich in den tempel und
pflegen gemeint auf die dass ihre eltern
getan haben nein eigentlich nicht also
man sieht ja sehr deutlich den
unterschied wer wo aufgewachsen wäre wo
sozialisiert ist für die eltern kommt
wenn wir an das beispiel eines
hindu-tempels nimmt am jüdischen tempels
ist dieser tempel auch sehr deutlich
eine gemeinschaft tamilisch gesprochen
da wird sozusagen auch rückbindung an
nach sri lanka an die herkunft an die
heimatliche kultur und religion gesucht
für die zweite generation ist mir sagte
dass jemand sind die rituale langweilig
sie dauernd lange sind unverständlich es
wird noch mit rauch gearbeitet
götter verehrt und so und wir sehen
mitunter dass die die mädchen sozusagen
sind gebeten dann auch mit den müttern
im tempel zu bleiben die jungs bleiben
draußen vor dem tempel bis auf wenige
ausnahmen schwitzen
und unterhalten sich über verschiedene
dinge sei es über fußball über mädchen
und kommen zum ende der pusher der
andacht rein da gibt es den segen hinter
gibt es das essen aber es ist eine ganz
andere einstellung und sie sagen heimat
ist für uns hier die schweiz und ist
nicht mehr so lang und wenn ich in sri
lanka bin war das ist für mich sozusagen
ein urlaub aber leben das könnte ich
nicht sie haben auch untersucht wie sich
religiöse jugendgruppen verhalten und
wenn die umsätze vor augen halten für
den kirchlichen bereich die zivis
blauring organisation die sind bekannt
anerkannt und ihre arbeit wird auch sehr
geschätzt aber schon wenn wir von
jüdischen jugendorganisationen oder dann
muslimischen jugendorganisationen vatis
beispielsweise hören dann denken wir
doch sofort ist das jetzt nötig oder ist
das eine form der abgrenzung warum
rauchten dass
sie sind eigentlich weit geht erst
einmal unbekannt was da läuft man muss
aber auch sagen ist eine minderheit ist
eine minderheit wir haben ungefähr wenn
die schätzungen wenn man sagen kann ja
100.000 120000 junge muslime jugendliche
junge erwachsene muslime und wir haben
plusminus 100 jugendvereine gefunden das
ist extrem wenig wir sehen es sind zehn
vielleicht 15 prozent von mosley machen
überhaupt in diesen vereinen mit der
großteil nicht also 85 prozent
möglicherweise machen nicht wegen dann
die mitmachenden zivilgesellschaftlichen
organisationen nicht sie sind in
sportvereinen drin sie sind in der wäre
drin sie engagieren sich in der schule
dass sie dort gute resultate bekommen
sie sind im konsumverhalten drin wie
viele andere schweizer jugendliche auch
dann wir sehen das in diesen um auf die
jugendgruppen zurückzukommen wir sehen
das in diesem jugendgruppen amtlich
aktivitäten sehr ähnlich sind wie bei
jugend blauring bei den pfadis adb
kirchlichen vereinen
freizeitaktivitäten wir sehen dass hier
aktivitäten wie sport anlässe wie steht
an lässt und so etwas organisiert wird
aber der unterschied ist es werden auch
religiöse inhalte vermittelt selbst
vermittelt die jugendlichen sind selber
miteinander lehrer aber beispielsweise
eine gruppe
versucht den oder ließ den koran erklärt
sie bestimmte dinge lädt man referenten
ein
mann hält selbstverständlich die
gebetszeiten 1 bei einem islamischen
jugendturnier fußball turnier haben wir
gesehen dass dort auch sozusagen die
sportkleidung relativ dezent war auch
dort gebetszeiten eingehalten wurden und
auch die geschlechtertrennung relativ
stark und deutlich war das heißt in
diesen jugendorganisationen
herrscht ein bisschen die die
vorstellung ganz oder gar nicht entweder
organisiert man sich in der gesellschaft
und dann ist man nicht in diesen
jugendorganisation oder wenn man dort
dabei ist dann geht es sehr wenige zu
und her nein das sehen wir nicht sondern
wir sehen es gibt eigentlich sehr wenige
hoch religiöse will jugendgruppen weil
das ist nicht attraktiv für jugendliche
jugendliche gehen hin weil es offen ist
falls interessant ist dort aktivitäten
angeboten wenn die jugend orientiert
sind und wo wir aber auch aussagen haben
wo anna sagte hier kann ich mich mit
anderen über die problematik über die
schwierigkeit einfach auszutauschen in
der schweiz ein muslim zu sein und wie
ich mein leben leben was kann ich essen
warum muss ich muss mich nicht mehr
begründen dass ich keinen alkohol trinke
und ähnliches da und es sind eigentlich
vereine die wagen nicht in den
untersuchungen gesehen dass wir jetzt
sozusagen hoch religiöse vielleicht
welche abkapseln wird sondern wir sehen
jugendvereine die
das vielleicht auch den inhalt aber
versuchen sich interreligiösen dialog
einzubringen wir sehen meint wegen wo
man mit einer christlichen jugend gruppe
zusammen eine
anlass durchführt und sagt was heißt für
mich muslim sein was heißt für mich
christ sein aber wir sehen eigentlich
den grad von zusagen engagement der ist
ähnlich wie bei anderen jugendvereinen
christlich geprägte oder nicht
christlich geprägter vereine und wir
sehen aber nicht so eine abschottung
sondern wir sehen das ist ein ort in dem
kraft geschöpft wird und dem das war das
letzte porträt von der jungen dame und
seiner identität geschaffen wird und man
weiß hier kirchen das gehört für mich
nicht kann religiös sein und in der
gesellschaft teilzuhaben eine lehre mein
beruf zu machen kann ich sehr gut
miteinander verbinden das wird auch
heißen dass das vielleicht eher so eine
vorübergehende attraktion darstellt wie
jugendliche die dort sich aufgehoben
fühlen und sich austauschen sicherlich
wir sehen eben wenn jugendliche älter
werden sie verlassen aufgrund
familienbildung aufgrund von aufnahmen
von studium von beruflichen engagement
sehen wir dass die jugendgruppen
verlassen wir sind einige jugendliche
die bleiben in den jugendgruppen drin
helfen hier wieder jüngeren und das
denke ich sind ganz wichtige rolle also
vorbilder und sie sagen auch wenn jemand
sagt warum soll ich diese al gore
mathematik lösung und um rechenaufgaben
machen dann sagt ein älterer
jugendlicher sagt schau ich lerne auch
noch ich bin hier an der universität
oder ich bin in der höheren lehre und
und über bildung nur schaffst du den
sozusagen teil zu werden und teil hier
in der gesellschaft fuß zu fassen und
auch einen guten job zu haben
die bedeutung der institutionellen
religion nimmt tendenziell ab bei uns in
der gesellschaft trotzdem betonen sie
oder wird in diesem buch auch betont
dass religionsgemeinschaften einen
zivilgesellschaftlichen nutzen haben wir
können uns einen nutzen vorstellen der
nutzen ist in dem er erst mal person
einbindet bindet person ein stellt
kontakte her und über was wir gerade
eben in dem buch was wir betonen ist
eben gerade christliche gruppen grad die
großen landeskirchen aber auch
freikirchen sind sehr sehr engagiert um
auch soziale missstände in der
gesellschaft aussehen und letztendlich
in einer gesellschaft für die schweiz
ist die sehr stark auf zivilgesellschaft
organisiert ist geht es über
institutionen geht es über vereine
freiwilligen vereine wir sehen eben in
der schweiz auch dass sie zu
freiwilligen engagement nach und nach
endlich zurückgeht das hängt natürlich
sehr stark mit individualisierung zu tun
und zusammen und konsumgesellschaft das
in andere angebote würden sie denn ganz
konkret
jugendlichen empfehlen die sich in
religiösen gemeinschaften engagieren
dieses als ein mehrwert hervorzuheben
beispielsweise bei einer lehrstelle
bewerben ich würde es hervorheben aber
ich finds begründen nicht weil sozusagen
in den köpfen ist natürlich das bild
islamische jugendgruppe ist das
abgeschottete das radikalisiert aber
wenn ich schreibe ich bin in einer
muslimischen jugendgruppe und habe ich
hier gemacht hausaufgabenhilfe ich habe
organisiert war einen interreligiösen
dialog anlass ich habe organisierten
ausflug nach dortmund dorthin das zeigt
diese person ist übernimmt verantwortung
und kann organisieren und was wir sehen
was in den jugendgruppen lohn vielfach
ist verantwortung übernehmen
organisieren lern und das ist natürlich
zivilgesellschaftliche fähigkeiten
gesellschaft kapital was man auch in
anderen bereichen gebrauchen kann sei es
im studium sei es im beruf sei es in
in bereichen wenn man in politische
parteien oder ähnliches geht bleiben wir
ganz kurz bei der frage des kapitals
erkennt unserer gesellschaft diese
anlage diese diese diese nötige
investitionen nicht das kapital
ich glaube noch nicht ich glaube sie
kennen das sehr gut bei christlichen
jugendgruppen sie kennt er sehr gut bei
blaubeuren jugendring weil bei
jugendwart bei den pfadi seppel und
ähnlichen dann da kennt sie das sehr gut
aber sie sieht wird dann aus ihrer
perspektive heraus mit der negativ folie
islam sieht sie noch nicht dass
ähnliches eigentlich läuft auch in
muslimischen jugend gruppen auch in
städtischen jugendgruppen oder
vietnamesisch buddhistischen
jugendgruppen hier wird organisiert und
dies organisieren lernen sie vor eine
gruppe stellen und zu sagen lasst uns
diskutieren lassen uns dies machen
organisieren jemand anzurufen dinge auf
die beine zu stellen das glaub ich es
wird mit der zeit stärker komm ich sehe
es in den lokalen gemeinden dass
beispielsweise
integrationsbeauftragte sind oft sehr
gut
informiert sie wissen darüber aber auf
der bisschen höheren politischen seite
dann wird sehr schnell dieses argument
religion auskennst nicht zugehören
instrumentalisiert und dann sind da mit
blockaden auch gelaufen ich glaube wir
müssen schauen was läuft in den
religiösen verein was läuft in den
jugendgruppen um dies einmal sozusagen
auch weniger von der religion zu sehen
sondern von den aktivitäten hier wir
kommen bereits schon zum schluss und
meine letzte frage wäre die nach dem
ausblick in die zukunft wohin läuft der
trend bei der dritten und später auch
vierten generation was die bedeutung der
religion angelangt es kann sein wie wir
aus amerikanischen studien wissen dass
die dritte rallye dritte generation
möglicherweise religiöser wird sozusagen
diese distanzierung zurücknimmt und und
sagt wir möchten mehr an die wurzeln der
eltern an das herkunftsland
es kann aber auch sagen dass dieser
trend der der ich gesellschaft wie mein
kollege dass jörg stolz gesagt hat
dieser trend der ich gesellschaft der
konsumgesellschaft weiter stark anhält
und und und die leute noch mehr sich von
religion distanzieren und ich glaube was
wir von der gesellschaft seite her sehen
müssen ich glaube wir müssen diesen
diesen von religion ii sierung sozusagen
die religion auflegen auf leute auf
stücke auf vereine man muss es einfach
bisschen nüchtern habe ich ein
entspannter sehen und sehen es ist nicht
religionen sozusagen per se positiv oder
negativ sondern wir müssen einfach
schauen wie stark ist religion hier drin
und nicht und diese religion easy
rousseff alle eigentlich die
zurücknehmen und schauen was sehen wir
vor ort und was ist wirklich vorzufinden
sie werden die entwicklungen weiter
verfolgen wie ihr auch ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei ihnen für dieses
gespräch
dann gehen auch sie mal
mit dem film den wir jetzt zeigen
bleiben wir beim thema ich bin ein
berliner sagte einst der amerikanische
präsident john f kennedy ich bin ein
berliner oder eine berlinerin sagen auch
die drei jungen menschen die sie gleich
kennenlernen werden eine art
kongolesische eine iranische und der
dritte
jüdische wurzeln